hi everyone it's joanna here these are
nine of my favorite dynamic stretches
which i like to perform as my warm-up
before exercising in today's class we
will be moving through the full range of
motion without folding the stretch so
dynamic stretches are great to increase
blood flow in our body and to get our
muscles ready for the real work so this
class is low impact and it's gentle
let's get started
grab a mat all right and we will be
working on your mat throughout the
entire class so let's start right at the
edge of your mat the first exercise is
going to be an inchworm into a downward
dog position so this workout is really
great if you have tight hamstrings okay
so what i'm going to do is start with
your knees slightly bent to begin with
all right so start with your knees
slightly bent reach down to the floor
slowly inch forward
into a plank position
and when you get into a plank position
making sure that your shoulders are in
line with your arms and slowly push your
butt back
into a downward dog position okay
and then back into a plank position and
slowly
drive your arms back
into
a standing position and reach up alright
are we ready 45 seconds
reach up
back down
starting with your knees slightly bent
get into a plank position
and now push your butt back
really feel the stretch on your back
back into a plank
and slowly inch back up
again reach down
and now try to keep your legs straight
if you want a deeper stretch on your
hamstrings
plank position
push your butt back
try to get your heels
to touch the floor
into a plank position and slowly inch
back up okay so we are moving throughout
the entire stretch good all right so
just shake it out a little bit the next
one is going to be a hip flexor stretch
same thing
what we want is to start in a plank
position
drive your
right feet forward
release your right hand and stretch up
back down
and back into a plank position okay
so right feet forward
reach up
tap down
and back
just working on one side
reach up
tap down
and back okay
and we will switch to
the other side
back
and down so this will really feel the
stretch on your hip flexor
okay
down
into a high plank
remember to breathe
feel the stretch
and back
one more
up
and back
into a high plank are we ready to switch
side
left feet forward okay reach up
twist
and back
up
and back good job
so
as you take a step forward
i want you to try to reach further
forward
feel a deeper stretch on the hip flexor
back down
and
up
good
back
twist
good job there you go if this is too
much for you what you can do is rest
your knee on to the floor
back
let's go for two more
back down
one more
up
and into a plank position
drop your knees take a short rest all
right next is going to be a three legged
dog into a cross crunch so same thing in
a high plank position
[Music]
reach your right leg up
and cross forward
okay
up
and drive your knee across
good job
switch it up feel the stretch
and
good there you go
so working on the strength of your core
at the same time
okay remember do not rotate your hips
maintain a square
hip position
reach
up
feel the stretch on your
leg
up and twist
good job all right switch the other side
high plank position
left leg up remember do not rotate okay
square your hips reach up
reach
push it up
and
reach
there you go
remember to breathe throughout the
stretch
go deeper okay
if you can try to stretch
further
through every wrap
up
look down
and reach
good
there you go
push into the ground
and cross
[Music]
doing well
one more
and reach
all right
now let's get into a standing position
all right slowly stand up
the next stretch is going to be a chair
twist okay so what i'm going to do is
bring your legs together
reach up
as you squat down twist
to the left
reach up and as you squat
twist
to the right okay
so
try to get your elbow to tap
your thighs
and really
twist and reach as far
as you can
good
pushing your butt back
so this is a great stretch
to warm up
the legs
and also
your back reach up all the way up twist
all the way up
and
up
okay all right now step right at the
edge of your mat okay
the next dynamic stretch is going to be
a forward lunge with rotation so really
warming up your core and to also get you
balanced as well so forward lunge
rotate
step back
forward lunge
rotate and step back okay
lunge forward
twist
and back
and back there you go
really twist
all the way to the left
and to the right
good job
this is great especially if you're doing
a lot of lower body workout
twist
and up
that's one more
and up okay next
really simple stretch
step wide
reach your arms out okay all i want you
to do is just
reach for your toes okay feel the
stretch on your hamstrings so i'm
forward
cross over
and just
reach all right if this is too much
just kick as high as you can okay don't
have to over stretch your muscles
try to reach if not a low cake
is good enough
all right
if not
let's bring your leg
up
kick
good job do the stretch and hamstrings
point your toes up
raise your core
[Music]
ah
good job
a few more
[Music]
and shake it out okay now let's focus on
your inner thighs inner thighs as well
as your outer thighs so take a wide step
it's going to be a side to side lunge so
all i want to do is lunge to the left
tap down reach to the right
and reach so feel the stretch on your
inner thighs okay
reach
and down and up
good job
moving through the full range of motion
and down
reach up good job
tap
for a deeper stretch
good
remember to point your toes
[Music]
a few more five more seconds
[Music]
tap down reach up
one more
and up okay now let's get back down onto
the mat let's get into all fours okay
the next stretch is going to work on
your glutes and also on your hip flexor
it's going to be a fire hydrant to a
kickback so
open up to the side kick it back
and back down
open up to the side kick it back
and back all right remember to keep your
hips squared so do not rotate your hips
too much
open it up fire hydrant kick it back
feel a slight squeeze on your glutes
and back into
the starting position
up
and back remember gaze onto the floor
okay do not look forward
up
kick it back
good job
and change the other other side so this
is my favorite stretch especially if i
know that i want to be working on my
glutes and hamstrings okay let's go
fire hydrant kick it back
fire hydrant and kick it back good job
up
and open
so brace your core
push into the ground
okay do not rush
through the stretch
i want you to really feel
the muscles you're engaging
get back
a few more
open
back
forward
and back down okay
one final stretch okay plank to bear so
start in a high plank position
all i'm going to do is fold your knees
and drive your butt back
and back into a plank okay
so fold it hold it for two counts
and back into a plank position
feel the stretch on your back
really try to push your butt as far back
as you can
and shift your body weight into a high
plank position
good job
again
gaze onto the floor keeping a neutral
spine alright do not look forward push
back
and
plank a few more you should also really
feel the work on your arms
one more and plank all right drop your
knees
okay
so
that is the end of your dynamic
stretches all right let's get into
standing position so that's a really
simple dynamic stretch routine that you
can perform before every workout session
this will really help to get the blood
flowing in your body and to really prep
your muscles so do this right before
every workout session so that you can
really have a good and effective workout
session and be sure to check out a lot
more workout videos on my youtube
channel i have a huge variation from
heat workouts to strength training body
weight exercises and even low impact
exercises okay and if you haven't yet
subscribed to my youtube channel then do
hit the subscribe button and let me know
what other workouts would you like to
see more of on my channel and i will see
you next time all the best